Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es hablar sobre
la Prueba de hipótesis, que es el corazón de la
estadística inferencial, la cual nos permite
hacer inferencias sobre el mundo. Entonces,
para darnos una idea general de esto comencemos
con un ejemplo tangible. Digamos hipotéticamente
que administramos un sitio web que tiene la misión
de brindar a todo el mundo una educación gratuita
y queremos saber cómo podría cambiar la cantidad
de tiempo que las personas pasan en el sitio. Lo
ideal sería aumentar la cantidad de tiempo
que las personas pasan en el sitio para que
su aprendizaje sea mayor. Bueno, actualmente
el sitio web tiene un fondo blanco como este y
la media del tiempo que las personas permanecen
en el sitio web cuando el fondo es blanco es de
20 minutos. Algunos de ustedes se encuentra un
estudio que dice que a la gente le gusta pasar
más tiempo con fondos amarillos. En realidad no
creo que sea cierto, pero sigamos con esto para
resolver el ejemplo. Entonces tenemos la hipótesis
de que si el sitio web tiene un fondo amarillo,
si cambia su fondo a amarillo, la media del
tiempo que la gente permanecerá en el sitio web
será diferente, no va a ser igual a la media
del tiempo que las personas permanecen cuando
el fondo es blanco. Entonces, la pregunta es
¿cómo comprobamos eso y cómo podemos confiar en
las inferencias que obtengamos de esta prueba?
Y ese es el corazón de la Prueba de hipótesis,
por ejemplo, la investigación médica; en realidad
casi toda la investigación implica alguna forma de
prueba de hipótesis. Entonces, ¿cómo hacemos esto?
Bueno, la forma de resolver esto es establecer
un par de hipótesis. La primera se conoce como
hipótesis nula. Y a menudo pienso en ésta como la
hipótesis del escéptico. Los escépticos piensan
que es difícil que algo cambie en este mundo,
o de los pesimistas, que sienten que es difícil
hacer una diferencia en el mundo, y por eso
siempre establecen esta hipótesis nula que dice:
Tú crees que estás haciendo una diferencia pero
no la haces. Así que la hipótesis nula establece
que la media del tiempo que las personas pasan
en un sitio amarillo será igual a la media del
tiempo que las personas pasan en el sitio actual,
el sitio con fondo blanco. Mientras que las
personas que piensan "¿cómo hago un cambio?,
¿cómo hago mejoras en el mundo?" tienen otro tipo
de hipótesis, y la llamamos hipótesis alternativa,
y la alternativa es que la media del tiempo en el
sitio con fondo amarillo es realmente diferente,
no es igual a la media del tiempo en el sitio con
fondo blanco. Entonces, ¿qué hacemos con esto?,
¿cómo trabajamos con estas hipótesis? Bueno, lo
que vamos a hacer es suponer la hipótesis nula,
luego construimos el sitio con fondo amarillo
y tomamos una muestra de las personas que usan
este sitio; después nos preguntamos: ¿cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener la media de la muestra?
-que es una estimación del parámetro de la media
verdadera-, ¿cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
esa media de la muestra si suponemos la hipótesis
nula? Y si la probabilidad de obtener esa media
de la muestra para el sitio con fondo amarillo
suponiendo la hipótesis nula es realmente baja,
entonces rechazamos la hipótesis nula, lo
que sugeriría la alternativa. Por otro lado,
si obtenemos una media de la muestra cuyo valor
sea cercano al que suponemos en la hipótesis nula,
entonces no podemos rechazar la hipótesis nula
y eso no sugeriría la alternativa. Ahora, para
hacer esto un poco más evidente -y veremos esto
en muchos videos-, si suponemos la hipótesis nula,
entonces hay algunas cosas en las que podemos
pensar, podemos pensar sólo en la distribución
general del tiempo que las personas pasan en el
sitio: se vería algo así. Suponemos que es una
distribución normal, y las distribuciones
normales o distribuciones similares a las
distribuciones normales son muy importantes para
la Prueba de hipótesis. Digamos que el tiempo
que las personas pasan en el sitio sigue una
distribución normal: aquí tendríamos la media,
y sabemos que la media del tiempo que las personas
pasan en este sitio con fondo blanco es igual a 20
minutos. Y recuerden que estamos suponiendo la
hipótesis nula, por lo que estamos suponiendo
que ésta es también la media del tiempo que la
gente pasaría en el sitio amarillo. Suponemos la
hipótesis nula y podríamos ver esto como tiempo
o distribución del tiempo en el sitio. Ahora,
una de las cosas de las que hablaremos en futuros
videos es que, si tenemos esta distribución
podemos llegar a otra distribución de las medias
de las muestras que podríamos obtener. Hay algo
más llamado Distribución muestral de medias, sé
que es muy confuso al principio y será para un
tamaño de muestra dado. Digamos que el tamaño
de muestra es 1000 -estoy inventando cosas,
pude haber dicho n, pero voy a hacer
que esto sea un poco más simple-. Bueno,
vamos a obtener métodos estadísticos para pensar
en esta distribución suponiendo la distribución
que tenemos a la izquierda, y resulta que esta
distribución se verá como la de la izquierda,
pero será más estrecha alrededor de la media,
se verá más o menos así. Y en realidad cuanto
más grande sea el tamaño de muestra, más estrecha
será. Recordemos que esto no es la distribución
del tiempo que las personas pasan en el sitio, si
tuviéramos que tomar varias muestras del tiempo
que la gente pasa en el sitio y calcular las
medias, esta es la distribución que se obtendría
de las medias de las muestras. Ahora, el centro
de esta distribución sigue siendo nuestra media
para el fondo blanco, que es igual a la media
para el fondo amarillo. Recordemos que estamos
suponiendo la hipótesis nula, así que cada
uno de estos puntos corresponden al tiempo
que alguien podría pasar en el sitio. Se puede
ver que en este caso hay una baja probabilidad,
mientras que aquí tenemos una media que podríamos
obtener para una muestra de 1000 personas, y vemos
que en este caso hay una baja probabilidad
de ello. Entonces, lo que haríamos es,
si podemos generar estadísticamente estas cosas
suponiendo la hipótesis nula -y no se preocupen
por esto en este momento, pues más adelante
descubriremos las técnicas para hacer esto y
los supuestos que necesitamos para hacerlo-,
lo que hacemos es tomar una muestra de 1000,
y luego podemos calcular la media de la muestra,
podemos calcular eso. Supongamos que obtenemos
una media de la muestra de 30 minutos y que estos
30 minutos están justo aquí, el centro es de 20
minutos. Lo siguiente que hacemos es decir ¿cuál
es la probabilidad de obtener un resultado de al
menos ese valor suponiendo la hipótesis nula?
Y esa probabilidad en estas curvas estaría dada
por la cola derecha aquí y la cola izquierda que
está igualmente lejos pero en el lado izquierdo.
Y lo que hacemos es calcular esta probabilidad,
que corresponde a estas áreas amarillas aquí,
y luego pensamos en la probabilidad de obtener
un resultado de al menos 30 minutos. Entonces,
la probabilidad de obtener una media de la
muestra, cuyo valor sea por lo menos el de una
media de la muestra igual a 30 minutos, suponiendo
la hipótesis nula, y eso es exactamente lo que
representan esas áreas amarillas. Y lo comparamos
con un umbral predeterminado, ese umbral es,
a menudo, del 5%, a veces del 1%; pero si esta
probabilidad es menor o igual al umbral y el
umbral a menudo se denota con la letra griega alfa
(α), decimos: "Oye, hay una probabilidad muy baja
para obtener un resultado de por lo menos el valor
que se obtuvo si suponemos la hipótesis nula",
y eso nos permitiría rechazar la hipótesis nula,
lo que sugeriría la alternativa. Tengan en cuenta
que no hemos probado la alternativa y tampoco
hemos demostrado que la hipótesis nula sea falsa.
Acabamos de decir que si suponemos la hipótesis
nula hay una probabilidad muy baja de obtener
un resultado de al menos el valor que acabamos
de obtener, por lo que rechazamos la hipótesis
nula. Ahora, si es al revés, si la probabilidad
de obtener una media de la muestra cuyo valor sea
al menos el que obtuvimos no es tan baja, si es
mayor que el umbral predeterminado, no se rechaza
la hipótesis nula. Por ahora lo dejamos aquí. En
futuros videos profundizaremos mucho más en todo
esto, pero esto es para darnos una idea de cómo
las Pruebas de hipótesis permiten que la ciencia,
o cualquiera de nosotros, comencemos a hacer
inferencias en las que podemos confiar.